the Mayon Volcano is rumbling nearby but
these students are getting on with
school like it's a normal day the
volcano has been spewing Gas Rocks and
lava for days but scientists at the
Philippine Institute of volcanology and
seismology are fibok say a violent
eruption isn't imminent yet
so right now there's nothing to worry
according to the mailbox but again we
are anticipating the worst case scenario
authorities say they'll have to move 25
000 people to temporary shelters if the
alert level is raised those living
within the seven kilometer extended
danger zone like habit graheda and his
family
habit remembers worse episodes of
eruption so they're already getting
ready to evacuate
I remember a strong one where rocks fell
and after 10 minutes we got flooded by
volcanic mud
this isn't to say habit isn't
apprehensive he worries the chickens
he's raising will get stolen a number of
those who fled to safety do return to
their homes during the day to safeguard
their properties but increasingly
they're not being allowed to
police have set up what they call Choke
points all over the province of Albay
around the six kilometer permanent
danger zone so they can stop people from
going in and out
nearly 15 000 people from the volcano's
immediate vicinity have fled to
evacuation camps
State volcanologists say the eruption
could last weeks if not months a
humanitarian crisis in the making
yet the government seized potential a
quiet eruption means tourists can watch
it from a distance and they've been
flocking it's going to be a big loss I
was saying with the farmers with natural
routine of the workers here it's going
to be an extraordinary situation for
Alibi but the tourists can always you
know compensate for the loss and in
every crisis There's an opportunity
dazzling as this orange Clovis It could
only mean disaster
Beautiful Disaster but a disaster
nonetheless
Barn below Al Jazeera I'll buy the
Philippines